talking about sublinear time local
access panel generators I put every word
possible in the title to confuse you
okay so the goal of this talk is to talk
about what happens when you want to
generate a huge random object okay and
the question is how can we generate
these things do we need to generate the
whole object upfront or can we generate
the parts that we need locally on the
fly okay so before I talk about the
history of this problem I want to just
give an example what about generating a
really large random graph so maybe I
want to access I want to test my
algorithm I want to test it on random
graphs and I only need like parts of it
so I'll just generate the parts that I
wanted the adjacency matrix on the fly
well this seems great when you're
talking about GNP and every entry is
independent but what happens okay I'm
still generating what happens if you
have a requirement that it's symmetric
so there's a dependency no big deal you
know when I generate IJ I'll just write
down the answer in ji okay what about if
I want to support like complicated
queries like what's the next neighbor
because once I output what's the next
neighbor then I kind of made a lot of
decisions along the way they could
affect things that happen later on so
the point is there are gonna be
dependencies and some of these
dependencies could come from the model
and other dependencies could come from
the types of queries you support okay so
I want to talk about some prior work so
let's start with just huge random
objects in general huge pseudo-random
functions were suggested were study and
and given in the incredible work of gold
right goldwasser and McCauley this was
incredibly important in cryptography in
complexity it's something that gets used
in pretty much everywhere
it was then Ruby Rakoff Oh Ruby Ruby
back off looked at a super huge
pseudo-random permutation
I know a Rheingold looked at something
called involutions which I never knew
what that meant but I'll just tell you
what it is it's um it's like a random
pair
of points in the domain so that X f of X
equals y and F of y equals x so kind of
everybody's paired off I and a and just
one other type of kind of hash function
that was considered by Mansur Rubinstein
var D and she was looked at and this is
really balls into bins type hash
function which is interesting because
it's a process it depends on throwing
the ball into the bin that was least has
the least number of balls in it so it's
actually a function that is somehow
inherently sequential and a and in that
sort of process but it can actually be
implemented locally as well okay now the
model of in implementing huge random
objects was proposed was given proposed
formalized and first studied by Goldratt
Goldwasser and Nussbaum
in 2003 they looked at a number of types
of objects random functions codes graphs
they gave a bunch of important
primitives
they showed for example how to sample
from binomial distributions and interval
some queries for functions there's
another work that looked at that as well
in the streaming literature by Gilbert
at all
and one of the I mean they did a lot of
things in this paper it's it's a big
paper but one of the things that they
talked about a lot in newspaper is how
to provide limited queries to random
graphs with a specified property so for
example I Hamlet I want to present a
random graph that has a Hamilton cycle
in it but appears like a random graph
okay so they focus on sort of
indistinguishability under small number
of queries in polynomial time and even
though they focus on that a lot I want
to see that they do present a lot of
results that they don't need that focus
I mean so they also have they have a lot
of results in there okay
so let's just talk about graphs a so
gold right gold was here nice poem give
some implementations of GNP graph this
is what I just said that have a specific
property
I mentioned planted Hamilton psycho but
also they may have color ability cleek
connectedness bipartite knees
the
kind of queries they talk about in this
work is mostly adjacency I'm actually in
the okay this is one type of result from
this paper in this type of result they
talk about adjacency type queries and
there's usually some sort of limitation
up to pull a logarithmic so the thing
looks like a random graph that has a
planted clique as long as you don't take
too many queries I mean it but there's a
notion of truthfulness so it will always
have the planted cliff what's what's not
what the point is it will look random it
may not actually be so random okay
another type of result that they give is
for sparse graphs the previous thing was
but it was uh also handled dense graphs
and dense type queries adjacency queries
but for sparse graphs you don't want to
store all I J you also may want to talk
about all neighbors because sparse
graphs you have found a degree so in
this case they give a constructions of
graphs that have degree at most poly
logarithmic they're indistinguishable
from uniform distribution on a few
queries and here they support both the
Jason C and all neighbor type queries
okay I all right so now or in this point
actually looked at sparse GNP graphs
here the degree is expected to be at
most poly log you know they probably
wrote it as I mean for them they were
thinking of constant but you could if in
the constraints will give later poly log
works to a they support also adjacency
and all neighbor they bound the number
of queries you're allowed to make in the
paper but actually they're a result you
just you can adapt their results so that
this bound is not necessary in some
settings which I'll mention and I'll say
something more about it later in the
talk okay and another final work I want
to mention about huge implementations of
random graphs is a very recent work of
Evan Levy Medina and Rosen and here they
show how to implement bar by see elbert
preferential attachment graphs what's
interesting about these graphs is
they're kind of like these rooted tree
forest structures but they're generated
by a very sequential random process
they're sparse but the degree is not
bound
okay so it doesn't fall into under the
previous situations they provide
adjacency they cannot provide all
neighbor because the degree is unbounded
but they do provide something called
next neighbor okay so I you know I've
looked down the adjacency list of no to
I I have gotten up to a certain point
and I want to know what's the next
neighbor so they've implemented that
type of query and they give no bound on
the number so they will eventually reach
you know if you keep asking enough
they'll eventually generate the whole
graph if you ask for enough locations
they'll eventually generate the whole
graph but what's very interesting about
this is that the you know there was some
process you know note I looks at the all
the previous nodes and picks one
according to the degrees of the previous
notes so how do you decide if I and J
are connected or how do you find all the
neighbors of node you you would have to
look at all the previous notes to you
and construct what their degrees would
have been and what you would have picked
or can you do something else and they
show that you can do something else and
you only need poly logarithmic make many
queries yeah yeah so the point is the
queries are not you know in order okay
the queries are I want to know about the
57th node and later I want to know about
the millionth node but I'm not going to
go through all of them in order my
queries are arbitrary and they show that
you don't have to recreate the whole
process of the graph you just have to do
poly logarithmic many time you need only
poly logarithmic amount of time to
figure out what the previous things
would have been so it's like think of it
it's an N node graph and they can get
poly lágrimas poly logarithmic time to
do the crease so what happens is they're
not actually you know there's not like
one graph that they're simulating and
figuring out would happen they're making
some choices but they're doing it in a
way that can be back consistent
and it's very beautiful this work I
haven't recommend it so okay so let me
talk a bit about the models so in the
model proposed by gold right gold was
here in this poem about huge random
graphs and objects there let's think for
a bit as huge being exponential size the
users not supposed to query more than a
polynomial a number of locations
although and it's sufficient to generate
a graph that looks random to a
polynomial time algorithm sometimes they
some of their implementations actually
give much more than this in some of
their definitions require more than this
but that is one of the ways to think of
it in the work of Evan Levy Medina and
Ron Rosen there I I would like to call
it big instead of huge okay these are
big random graphs big is polynomial size
you might eventually write down the
whole graph but you don't want to pay
the cost up front so the end result
should be random according to the
claimed process and not just
pseudo-random but actually random okay
so there would be some so it's kind of
stronger as far as the end result but
weaker as far as the what we what the
size of graphs that we need to handle
are okay so that's a little bit of a
difference of the aims of these models
it's not to say that the results here in
the results here are are disjoint that's
not true
but um but this is just an attempt to
kind of characterize the aims okay all
right so sort of the standard so let's
compare also to the standard paradigm in
the standard paradigm if I want to
generate a random graph I'm given some
random bits some random random model
parameters we put it through the
generation algorithm you write down the
big graph and then the user interacts
with this thing that got written down
right but here you're getting random
bits and model parameters and this
generation algorithm doesn't do anything
it sort of interacts with the user the
user makes queries and as there is a
queries things get written down in this
side place and the user gets responds
and eventually this random object gets
written down in memory so the queries
reveal partial information and we're
it's on the fly okay so eventually the
entire object is sampled and stored in
memory it needs to be consistent and the
thing needs to come from the right
distribution in the end and not just a
pure random but to actually be from that
same distribution okay so what we'd like
is we'd like to be able to answer the
queries in poly logarithmic time we'd
like okay
I'd like a succinct representation in
the sense that if we have a degree D
regular graph I don't want to use N
squared bits to describe it okay we'd
like to be consistent over future
queries or so we can allow we do allow
here to store past decisions but
eventually you need to give up a valid
sample and we'd like distribution
equivalents that we output something in
this epsilon close enough one distance
to the goal distribution and this issue
of the what we're not going to talk
about today's pseudo-random
distributions these are indistinct which
would be indistinguishable from the goal
distribution or somehow preserve a
properties we're not gonna limit the
number of queries and we're not gonna
ask for a very succinctly
you know we're not thinking of the graph
is being exponential size and we only
get to store polynomial space we're
thinking of the graph is polynomial size
I can store it if I need to but I just
don't have the time to write everything
down upfront that's sort of a different
goal okay
that is the notion of g-g-g-gia
what you're suggesting and that may be
sufficient in many cases and then you
would go to the definitions of ggs here
we're asking for pretty much the right -
I mean this epsilon closed in l1
distance this is really error that we
get from implementation issues because
we need to approximate these CDF's and
sometimes we're a bit off it's not
really like that we're generating
different graphs or missing something
okay so it's a little bit or just
generating a certain subset that looks
random so it's nothing like that it's
really just that comes from the
implementation issues that we didn t go
to enough bits in generating our CDF
okay all right all right so I want to
talk a bit before I get into the results
I want to talk about the types of
queries so what kinds of queries do
people make from their graphs like
vertex pair we queries this you're asked
is edge UV present all neighbors you
might give node you and ask what are all
the neighbors of you degree you might
ask what's the degree of you what's a
neighbor of you what's the next neighbor
of you and you might even ask what's a
random neighbor of you okay so you know
if you can do all neighbors then you can
do all the rest of these but if you're
not in a sparse graph then these might
be more complicated so when your graph
is not sparse then I don't know what to
do about these I mean nobody has really
studied these so open question next
neighbor was studied by these guys by
Evan at all even when the graph is not
sparse as in the preferential attachment
graphs and he will talk about it today
in GNP as well and we'll also talk about
random neighbor for GNP okay
so what's nice about random neighbor is
it allows you to take a random walk even
when you're in a large degree graph and
you don't have the all neighbors query
ok so let's talk about some new
generators we're going to talk about GNP
stochastic block model and small world
graphs
okay so vertex pair query easy okay if I
just want to support vertex queries will
just generate on the fly will toss the
coin is needed you
me if I and J are connected I look there
if it wasn't tossed already I'll toss a
coin and write it down okay so that one
is easy I okay but what about sparse
graphs okay so I'm going to talk about
an implementation that's really adapted
from Noor in this one here you know you
don't I mean you're not gonna go through
the whole graph and fill in which ones
are green and which ones are white but
what you could do is define the edges
via ports okay so for each node you're
gonna pick a certain number of ports
depending on what its degree should be
and those will be those green guys these
are all the green kites are going to be
the port well we don't okay so we don't
know how to define this thing but what
we'll do is sort of pick the degree and
give a number of ports equal to the
degree of each of these nodes and then
to decide what the edges are will match
ports so those red things here say that
okay there's an edge between five and
three okay so we'll just match ports
okay how do we do that well first it
helps to notice that the following two
processes can be made equivalent okay
you can either pick the number of edges
for each you you know think of it
this is GNP for a small P right so just
think about estimating how many and just
pick a random thing with the right
distribution on how many edges each u
has and then sum it up to get the total
number of edges or you could pick the
total number of edges first and then
kind of divide it up among the use okay
and this means you and how would you do
that well okay I'll talk about actually
I'll talk about this in a bit but then
once you can do this what it means is
you can compute use locations where the
locations are abused ports so you think
of these green things of being actually
one long list instead of nicely done
like this but you'd like to figure out
which ones belong to node 5 so it turns
out you can do this using interval
subbable functions by GGI KMS and also
GG n and and and everybody looked at
those things okay so you can
use those to figure out where use
locations should be so then when you are
given an all neighbor query say let's
say for node six what you can do is
match its ports to other unmatched ports
okay and I'm not going to fully describe
that right now but I'm going to talk
about similar ideas later on and give
more pictures for how to do that but
it's all using these notions of into her
interval summable functions first of all
you have to figure out where no fixes
ports are and then you have to have kind
of a collection of the unmatched
currently unmatched ports and you need
to pick from them randomly and you can
do it with interval subbable functions
yeah I don't that's harder I'm not gonna
do that yeah I'm gonna allow parallel
edges in cells in this in this
particular implementation yeah okay all
right
I
I will say that if you don't want the
parallel edges in self loops then they
will do something else I so we a so um
what about next neighbor query okay so
now what's his next neighbour like I we
you query next neighbor on you so you
have like figured out what the first
like ten neighbors are for you then
you've figured out that okay it's
connected to one it's connected to three
it's connected to ten what's the next
neighbor
okay along the adjacency list so you're
starting at the last found neighbor you
know if if you're in the dense case you
can just flip coins until you toss a
heads right just go down the row um if
it's already been tossed and it's a
heads great but if it hasn't been tossed
toss the coin eventually you'll see a
heads how long till you see a heads
these are all independent coin tosses
time one over P okay so that's great
except that's great when P is constant
or at least one over poly log n what do
you do when P is little o of one you
know like one over square root n or
something like that alright so you could
use the Omni Burke weary of Noah in this
point that we just talked about and that
works when P is really really small like
less than logarithmic in poly logging in
O divided by n okay so but there's a big
gap between these two cases
I so think I mean right in the middle
square root n okay so think of that so
in this case the idea is gonna be
instead of just going down the row
flipping coins until you find a one why
don't we just sample the length of the
zeros run according to the
hypergeometric distribution so that
seems like easy enough we should be able
to do that the only challenge is gonna
be that some of these entries were
already filled in okay so let's see what
to do so this is we're gonna call this
skip sampling that's to pick the next
neighbor queries and this let's think
for a minute of a directed graph and
let's also assume that nobody did any
adjacency queries for us in the middle
that we're just doing that
neighbor queries I mean everything can
be handled but it's messy so let's just
think I mean it's a little bit of a mess
let's just think there's only next
neighbor queries that's all we're doing
okay and this is directed graphs okay so
we've done the next neighbor queries up
to here we figured all this out okay so
what we'll do is pick the length of the
0 run ago according to a hyper geometric
distribution and how will we do that
we'll toss something you know we'll pick
her in a number between 0 & 1
and do a binary search on this CDF of
this thing and we once we pick the
length of the 0 run will fill the next
entry I okay so we're picking let's say
we pick K so will we started at I comma
J will pick will fill in I J plus K with
a 1 okay so we picked the next there was
a run of four zeros and then the fifth
thing is a 1 that's what we picked okay
so we'll fill this in with a 1 and
that's the idea that's the whole idea
so in this case because it's directed I
don't have any worries that the other
neighbors filled in any of these things
and also I made that assumption very
conveniently that there were no vertex
pair queries okay all right so this is
good kind of except
does it bother anybody
yeah it takes too long to write down
these zeros okay so that that's a
problem we have to talk about that okay
so let me just answer we're not gonna
write down those zeros we're just gonna
write down the ones we see okay so
that's how we're gonna this is what
we're gonna do that's gonna be like the
theme here we're worried about small P
there's gonna be a lot of zeros and a
lot less ones we're just gonna write
down the ones so that's how we're gonna
solve that all right so what do we do
when it's an undirected graph okay so
here we have a similar thing we pick the
zero length of the zero run according to
the hypergeometric distribution we
filled in the next entry but uh-oh you
know this was already a zero so is that
okay well so we have to talk about that
okay so some of them note like some of
the locations here may have already been
determined by the other neighbor and if
that's the case we need to make sure
we're still outputting according to the
correct distribution okay and then
there's this issue that faith brought up
do we need to write all the zeros and I
already answered that I said we're not
gonna write down all the zeros we're
only gonna write down the ones okay and
we have to talk about how we're gonna
write down the ones all right so here's
how we're gonna do it for each node I
we're gonna maintain the last seen
neighbor J so this is the last one we've
seen so far that means that everything
before J has been determined okay but
what the way we're gonna write down what
came before J is we're only going to
write down the locations of the ones two
and six and then implicitly anything
else is a zero up to here because
everything up to here has been
determined
so everything up to here is a zero
that's not in this list okay now the
other thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna keep track of the other ones out
here that have been determined by other
neighbors all the ones out here we're
gonna keep as a min heap so I always
want to know which is the next one so
far from the other neighbors okay now
these zeros may be a lot of these zeros
had been determined by the other
neighbors
we will not keep track of that and we'll
show that most of the time we don't need
to know which ones are zeros so we're
gonna keep it so the rows the zeros here
we're not keeping track of but the thing
to notice is like we can figure out if
the neighbor made that into a zero
because if the neighbor made that into a
zero that means the neighbor has been
coming down and it's already reached
past this row right so we can just ask
the neighbor who are your ones and if
that is not one of the ones of the
neighbor then I know it has to be a zero
okay so so we can figure out from the
neighbor whether this is a zero or a one
all right good so we keep track of the
zeros implicitly the ones explicitly and
these are in a min heap there's a lot of
question marks too so if the neighbor
didn't call this a zero or one it's a
question mark all right so what are we
gonna do so we we do some skip sampling
and we choose K according to the
geometric distribution and we pick you
know we decide that where the next one
should go now I wrote that the next one
should go here but let's say I picked
the next one should go here that means
passed them in one in my mini this is
where the this is the next one in our
min heap if I picked something that went
past this min one forget it just output
this guy okay all right now let's say I
didn't pick something past but maybe I
picked something that landed on a zero
here
maybe my neighbor thought it should be
zero and I picked that there should be a
one landing right there so that's not
good because it conflicts with what my
neighbor thought okay we're going on the
principle that the first person to toss
the coin wins okay so if I pick a one
here but my neighbor already decided it
to zero then my neighbor wins and it's a
zero it's not a one okay so what we're
gonna do and it turns out this actually
is okay to do we're gonna re-roll
starting here though so starting here
we're gonna run we're gonna pick another
run length and it turns out that works
okay the other possibility is when we
started from here we ran a and picked a
one right here
like in the picture we picked up a one
here like in the picture and a let's see
what happens there everything's fine I
had a zero here but the neighbor said it
was already a zero but it doesn't
conflict with anything I chosen okay is
that okay I don't know but it will have
to I have to can I mean I haven't I
haven't really tried yet to convince you
that this is the right a distribution
but I'm just sort of telling you what
the algorithm is for now okay but what I
want to mention that would not have
happened is it's not possible that I
went out here and that the neighbor had
a one here because if the neighbor had a
one here we're going on the principle
that whenever the neighbor picks
something to be a one yes to tell us
about it okay so if he told us about it
it would have been on our min-heap and
and this would not have been our first
one this would have been our first one
we would have been told about it okay so
this is not a one this has to be a zero
but there's something kind of weird
going on here because we're somehow re
picking certain random bits like we're
eating it turns out that if you think
about it it's actually okay
like if you're picking you know if I'm
picking the length of the run it's kind
of a fast way of tossing a bunch of
coins in parallel but if we go on the
principle that each box can have two
coins and the first one decides okay so
I don't get you know like already this
coin was determined so I flipped an
extra coin so what it doesn't matter it
doesn't affect anything but this had
been tossed earlier and it was tossed
completely uniformly so I it turns out
that if you actually go through the
analysis it works out all right I don't
know if I'm gonna be able to convince
you that in the rest of this talk so
what I'm gonna say is I'm gonna give you
an alternate way to do this in a few
slides but it this actually works okay
so this why correct distribution I
didn't really try to explain I'm not
going to I'm gonna leave it for another
method
yes yes okay so so okay so what I want
to just where are we now we talked about
the next neighbor
we said okay through the minute I toss a
one so what's important here is I wanted
you to see the ideas of the algorithm
it's important every time you toss a one
you have to tell your neighbor that he
also got a one there and he needs to
store it somehow okay so we need to
inform the the neighbors and what about
the non neighbors do we need to inform
them with the zeros well it turns out
you can figure that out so so these are
all things we can handle what we didn't
talk about but can be done is how to
combine next neighbor and vertex pair so
you need to keep track of a little bit
more information if you do vertex pair
queries in addition to what we did a
careful analysis can mitigate all these
issues but what about the random
neighbor query how do we sample a random
neighbor without knowing or committing
to a degree okay so we don't get we
don't know the degree all right so in
the dense case no problem okay in the
dense case we can just I want a random
neighbor of I so just pick a random J
see if it's a neighbor I mean maybe it
was decided already and if not I'll toss
a new coin and if it's not a neighbor
I'll try again pick a new random J until
I find one that's a neighbor and if this
case this is dense enough then the time
is going to be pretty quick it'll be
time order one over P so just like
before and again we want to do little o
of one over P also in the sparse case if
we actually have all neighbor queries we
can just pick a random one of you know
after I got the all neighbor query we
can just pick a random one and say
that's the random neighbor okay so
that's easy what about the intermediate
case that we just talked about okay so
the idea here is going to be two equally
partition each row in two contiguous
buckets and we're gonna pick the sizes
of these buckets so that the expected
number of neighbors in each bucket is a
constant okay so with high probability
we're gonna we're gonna pick it so that
most of these buckets are non empty and
furthermore in no book
it has more than logarithmically many
neighbors okay and that's and so can we
do this drumroll yes if we can do this
then we can instead of keeping track of
all of the zeros and ones in the bucket
all we have to do is write down the
logarithmically many neighbors in each
bucket so I only need log information
per bucket to write down okay well how
many buckets so what I want to make
clear here is we're gonna have P n
buckets each of size one over P okay so
when P is a constant that's lots and
lots of buckets it's linear in n buckets
each one of constant size in the sparse
case when P is like C over n then we're
gonna have very small buckets okay but
let's just think the case where P is 1
over square root n you might have square
root on buckets so that's lots of
buckets and they might all be big
because they might all be screwed in
size okay so we don't have any notion
that the number of buckets is small or
that the size of the buckets are small
they're all too big for us okay
okay so what do we do with the bucketing
now we've picked a size so the expected
number of neighbors in a bucket is theta
of 1 and also order of log in with high
probability
so the number of neighbors is roughly
the number of buckets okay so if I want
to know okay so I want to know a random
neighbor of V we've taken its name it's
it's row I'm the adjacency matrix kind
of in our heads and partitioned it into
these buckets what we're gonna do is
first pick a uniform random bucket and
then fill the bucket if it hasn't been
filled previously okay what do we mean
by fill let's we said these buckets
could be really big so I'd really don't
want to go down one by one and fill this
bucket right so we'll talk about that
okay but we're gonna but in the end once
you fill the bucket you're going to keep
a list of the ones in the bucket
remember there's only logarithmically
many of them and then from that we can
just pick a neighbor inside the bucket
very quickly so step two is once the
bucket is filled and I've got this list
of login many ones at most log in many
ones pick one of those quickly
you uniformly okay and now we have to
decide do we want to output this you or
do we want to you know is this a good
sample to output well the problem is
some of the buckets might have
logarithmically many neighbors some of
the buckets might have zero or even just
one neighbor so if I picked a bucket
that had lots of neighbors then each one
of those has smaller probability of
being output and I want to pick
uniformly so we'll just do a rejection
sampling to fix this right we know that
there's a most Luggin many neighbors for
example so all we have to do is return
you with probability number of neighbors
in the bucket divided by log n and if we
don't return you then just try again
okay so what's the probability we return
neighbor U of this V it's 1 over the
number of buckets that's we had to pick
the right bucket and step one in step
two we had to pick you from all the
neighbors of V so that's 1 over the
number of neighbors in the bucket and
then we have this rejection sampling
thing which is a number of neighbors in
that bucket divided by a fatal log n
these guys cancel out and remember that
1 over the number of buckets is like 1
over the number of neighbors okay and
it's the same for every u so that's
gonna be Omega 1 over log n times number
of neighbors of V where V was V is the
original guy that we wanted arrange
random neighbor so this is the right you
know one over the number of neighbors of
V is the right distribution but divided
by log n so there so what this means is
the probability we return something in
any loop is something like 1 in log N
and if you do this logarithmically many
times you're gonna output you're finally
gonna have something to output and it's
gonna be uniform distribution okay so
that's the that's the plan with the
bucketing okay so what we haven't
described is how to fill this bucket
okay and it's good I mean this is why I
did the previous slides
it's just so that you can see here what
to do so the bucket might already have
been indirectly filled in certain
locations because of the neighbors okay
now what we're gonna bank on is when
those neighbors fill buckets if they
created any ones they had to tell us
about it
okay so any ones that neighbors stuck in
our bucket they have to tell us about so
we know those so ones were reported when
they were created the zero entries that
neighbors might have stuck in our bucket
they didn't tell us about but it if we
ever need to know if it was a zero or
one we're gonna be able to figure it out
from looking at the complimentary bucket
the one that went this way all right so
what we're gonna do first is just skip
sample in the bucket ignoring all the
existing entries okay so this is just on
our own we skipped sample okay we had a
run of length two followed by one
another and this is a terrible skip
sample but that's this like it's a run
of length two followed by one run of
length two followed by one run of length
zero followed by one and so on okay so
that's how we fill this bucket and now
we go back and compare to what we knew
now what so what we want to do is
something that only depends on the
number of one entries in either here or
here okay because we know there aren't
so many of them we do not want to sit
there and expect every single zero okay
so what we're gonna do is we knew we had
some ones that were attached to this
bucket from the neighbors okay
go and take those ones these two ones
here and stick yeah and you know just
replace what the bit that we chose we
chose something random but they chose
something random too okay and they did
it first so just put it in there okay
and for each new green one entry you
remove it okay so so we had these guys
these guys just get replaced now this
was picked before this so this needs to
be a zero right all right so what we're
gonna do is for each of our green ones
there's only a small number of them
we're gonna check maybe it was supposed
to have been a zero and if it was a book
and how do we check that we go back here
and check the neighbor did you fill it
in and what number did you give it okay
if they filled it in then they either
gave it a one in which case they agree
with us so we can keep it or they gave
it a zero in which case we're going to
change it so where is an example of that
here we had a one but they gave it a
zero so we're changing this to a zero
okay now the point is we only have to do
this for the ones we already had which
we're only a number a constant number
and the ones we newly generated which is
also only a constant number so we don't
have to spend much time just a constant
amount of time to figure out what to fix
on this so the one thing you have to
believe me is that it's okay if you toss
a coin twice to just take the second
coin okay so now why is this fast the
number of one entries is okay we said
that good
so we're there all right so the nice
fact is this bucketing idea also
improves the next neighbor queries okay
so this is okay to do all right so I
have a little bit of do I have any time
left okay so I'll just say stochastic
black model you know I think people have
seen stochastic block model so a again
what we're gonna do here is the
difficulty here is we also have to pick
for each node which community it's in
and we're gonna use the multivariate
hypergeometric distribution this is
something that we've studied in other
works so I think I'm not going to show
you I don't have time to show you that
it's got another use is that you can
partially sample a random walk but this
is it's a really easy idea if I want to
know where a random walk is at time T
this is again it's this kind of a
straightforward application of them of
the distributions that all those other
people showed how to do we can figure
out a position of a random walk at time
P through the random walk that goes plus
1 with probability 1/2 minus 1 with
probability 1/2 and these I'm sorry
these are what do you call these things
these a there's a word for it the aggi
km/s called it a these interval
somewhere about query functions will
tell you I you can kind of figure out so
there's some random function and you can
figure out between I and J what's the
sum of the function and you can
implement these queries in logarithmic
time and if you can do it for a random
function such that you only have to fill
in the parts of the random function
as needed sort of okay and and in with
this you can kind of do you can return
query heights of a random walk they came
from something that's possible to
complete to something that looks random
I another thing one can look at its
small world graphs this is a the model
of Kleinberg where you start with the
grid and then you add some directed long
range edges with probability C over the
distance squared so and what we're gonna
answer here this is going to be a
constant degree graph so we'll answer
all neighbor queries which implies
implementation for all the other queries
we talked about and here the issue here
is most DS you don't have these long
ranged edges for most distances okay so
what we're gonna do is sort of use the
CDF of the probability distribution on
which distances you'd be far to pick
which distance is to put the edges at
and once I know that I have something at
distance a3 I'll go around all the edges
of distance three and we'll skip sample
them okay to figure out where which ones
get filled okay and that's a way that
you can do this without having to try
all possible DS okay so future
directions what about other random
objects many have been studied but many
haven't and what about supporting degree
and I've never questioned what about
local generation without history so
those are the
[Applause]
but you that I need kind of say